بالرغم من مرور ثلاثه واربعين عاما على
اخر حادثه طيران في السعوديه
الا ان اعدادا كبيره من السعوديين يواجهون
مشكله مع ركوب الطائره
اسباب مختلفه اثرت بشكل رئيسي على هؤلاء
المسافرين الذين اختاروا اكمال رحلاتهم
برا او بحرا هروبا من سيناريو هاتي رحله
الطيران محمد بن سلمان احد الذين يعانون
من فوبيا الطيران حيث كانت اخر رحله
استقلها قبل تسع سنوات تقريبا وبعد ان
واجهت الطائره صعوبه في الهبوط اكثر من
مره قرر محمد ان ينهي علاقته برحله
الطيران الى الابد
طلبنا منه القدوم للمطار في محاوله لكسر
هذا الحاجز همم
يعني انا كل ماجيت احاول انه مثلت انا
والعائله اسافر انا والاصدقاء اممم يعني
اضغط على عمري ولكن لا استطيع كلا من
الفوضى هذه وصرت اممم الاهل يسافرون
لحالهم الاصدقاء يسافرون انا اجلس الرهاب
ما بعد الصدمه اللي هو احيانا كثير يكون
هناك مسافر عنده تجربه سيئه اثناء ركوب
الطياره انه صار حادث مثلا كثره المطبات
في الاجواء او انه مثلا صار عطر في
الطائره او احد المحركات توقف عن همم
العمل يصير عنده نوع من الرهف فجاه يعني
يرفض حتى انه
يستخدم الطيران كوسيله للسفر يحولها هؤلاء
المسافرون اقناع محمد بالعدول عن رايه
ومعوده السفر بالطائره بعد هذا الانقطاع
وبالرغم من رغبته الكبيره بمواجهه هذه
المشكله الا ان محاولاته ما زالت مستمره
منذ تسع سنوات لا زلت احاول اني ابحث عن
حلول واا تعرفيه ناس يقولوا لكم والله همم
حبوب تاخذها او علاج نفسي بالعكس يمكن انا
رحت لدكتور نفساني
واعطاني حبوب قال ما يدي يعلمني هو ان
اطلب اياها طيران واعطاني حبوب ولكن اخذت
حبوب مره قلت بجربها قبل ما اسافر
فجربتها حسيت اني مازلت متوتر من اسم
السفر اسم السفر وخصوصا لما اذكر الطائره
انصح في اول الامر اذا انت وجدت مشكله
عندك انك تعترف بالمشكله تلجا للمتخصصين
سواء ان اطباء نفسيين المعالج السلوكي
والمعالجه المعرفي في التعامل والتفاعل مع
هذه المرحله بدايه اذا انت عالجتها مبكرا
من السهل التعامل معهم من سهل العلاج
والعوده والاستمتاع بالسفر واستمتاع
الطيران ليست فوبيا الطيران المشكله
الوحيده التي تساهم في الابتعاد عن ركوب
الطائره فالبعض يعزل الامر الى انزعجه من
الاماكن المغلقه او ما يسمى برهاب
بالاحتجاز فيما يواجه كثيرون خوفهم
بالاستمرار في السفر مهما كثره المطبات
الهوائيه من الرياض عبد الواحد الحميد
العربيه